pleased to say we're joined now bye
nadeem zahari the minister
responsible for the vaccine rollout mr
sahab we good to have you on the program
this morning and
my goodness there is a huge amount of
pressure on your shoulders
isn't there um in essence it looks like
we need to be moving from
300 000 vaccinations a week to 300 000
vaccinations a day now even by hercules
famously exacting standards that is a
herculean task in front of you
it is and it is a big task uh the nhs
both in england scotland wales and
northern ireland
have got a very clear delivery plan and
the plan is
as we launched initially with pfizer a
novel vaccine in hospital hubs then into
what are called primary care networks so
a network of five or six
gps coming together one leads and then
they begin vaccinations that has grown
massively that's the 730
the bulk of that delivery network now
we then go to national vaccination hubs
that the nhs have got planned and of
course the community pharmacies and the
independent
pharmacy sector as well so it's a
massive
effort uh by nhs england and england nhs
scotland wales and northern ireland
and they have a very clear plan they've
delivered 1.3
million over 1.3 million uh doses
already a quarter of those so one in
four
uh 80 year olds uh have already had the
first
jab the vaccination and in a couple of
weeks time that those
you know 25 of 80 year olds
will be protected and of course will
then get their second job as well so it
is a
herculean effort um i'm pleased to see
kirstama saying that we need to come
together i hope we get the support
of all political parties all members of
parliament
and the whole country as we're seeing
volunteers coming through the national
volunteering service
and thank you to the sun newspaper for
their campaign
and of course to send john's ambulance
who are leading on the volunteering and
nato's professionals as well let's just
talk
about about the achievability of that
which the government has set
out we heard from the prime minister the
ambition is of course to get you know
nine on 14 million people vaccinated by
the middle of next month but by the end
of this month we're looking at around
about 2 million
vaccinations every week um we heard
chris whittie say that this was
realistic but not easy matt hancock
suggesting
this is a best case scenario i mean how
would you categorize it
doable at a stretch
it's a big target and i think the prime
minister's right to
uh set us challenging targets uh we need
to
get on with this and do it as quickly
but as safely as possible which is why
again i commend the nhs for the plan
that they've put
in place the military are embedded in
the
in the team and i pay great tribute to
brigadier phil prosser
of 101 logistics brigade who absolutely
is
there focused on this delivery program
so it is a coming together
of you know the nation to deliver this
it is a stretching target no doubt
very stretching target but i'm confident
that you know
with this plan that the nhs have put
together we will deliver this
sure i i hate to keep hammering the
point but there have been occasions
throughout this pandemic where the
government has perhaps over-promised and
under-delivered taking the 14 million by
the middle of next month and 2 million a
week look
if we are getting two million
vaccinations a week by the end of this
month let's just
gently suggest that that would be a
total of eight million
charitably by the end of the month that
means
six million doses in two weeks now it's
early in the morning my mathematical
skills are pretty rudimentary
but you know six million divided by two
weeks is
three million vaccinations a week two
million a week
in and of itself if we hit that we're
not going to hit the target next month
isn't that
analysis accurate well i'm confident
that as we begin to deploy and
get more sites uh operational
i talked about the hospitals the gps of
course the community pharmacies and the
national vaccination centers
so we will be at over a thousand
sites vaccinating i'm confident you will
see
uh certainly from the 4th of january to
the 11th of january
a real step up so we've done
over 1.3 million uh since the 8th of
december you're going to see a massive
acceleration
of that but we need to do more than 2
million doses a week don't we
to get to that 14 million target in the
middle of next month
yeah no absolutely and you're going to
see the the that increase the nhs have
got a very clear plan
uh we've got a fantastic team uh working
seven days a week all hours to deliver
this
and as i said i think it's a stretching
target
no doubt it is a stretching target but i
think it's one that we should absolutely
uh uh look to deliver because if we do
deliver that and deliver the
those one to four categories that the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization
have uh identified are the most
vulnerable then
you will hopefully see that uh you know
a couple of weeks later reflected
in the the coming down
of the hospitalization rates and
ultimately mortality begins
to also be impacted so we see less
people dying from this
horrible virus just in terms of the
the problems that there may well be at
the moment one that has been identified
and
referenced by the prime minister
yesterday was that was the batch testing
of the virus once the the fit and fill
section of the
the production process has taken place
it is taking as long as perhaps 20
days for batches to receive that
approval
how can we trim that down but remain
safe so so there are a couple of things
so
first of all when the bulk vaccine goes
to the fill and finish
operation then it does need to
effectively go through a number of tests
including something called the sterility
test
now different batches are in different
timelines for that
the mhra and i again pay tribute to june
rain and her team
are doing everything in their capability
to do it
properly without cutting corners and
safely
to test then every batch because the
worst thing we can do
is uh in a national vaccination program
that is the biggest in this nation's
history
is to get this wrong and to have you
know a vaccine that is
not effective effectively being used so
it is important but we do look at each
and every step to make sure
that it is done as efficiently as
possible
and as we get more volume coming through
from the manufacturers
uh you i'm confident that we've got
enough visibility to be able to really
go after that prime minister's target
of uh mid-february being able to deliver
you know north of uh 14 million
uh doses and offer those to those first
one to four categories
just in terms of the the the assets that
we're using to get the vaccine into
people's arms there are some
uh within the pharmaceutical within the
the pharmacy industry i should say
rather than the pharmaceutical industry
those working in pharmacies
there appear to be thousands of people
there who of course are
experienced in the administration of
vaccines because of the the influenza
vaccine
why are they not already being stood up
to being used it does seem like
there is a resource lying there waiting
to be taken up with the government
there is a very important resource and
we are taking it up
and we're working with the uh community
pharmacy
sector very important sector and of
course the independence as you
mentioned as well what we did was stand
up the hospitals first because as chris
whittie has quite rightly
uh uh identified when you have a novel
vaccine you want to make sure
that as you you know increase the
numbers of people being vaccinated you
do it
in a careful way where you can observe
people the regulator has a what is
called the yellow card system so that we
see
uh how people are uh you know reacting
to the vaccine
in a very safe way and then we go into
gps
gps
are the most effective way of getting
into say for example
the care homes it's very important in
those
that first category in fact is to get
into care home residence and that's the
best way to get into care homes
so we went with the gps which is the nhs
plan i was talking about
then international vaccination centers
which you will see uh
uh imminently and then uh into the
uh community pharmacies and the
independent sector so every sector
will play a part in this and i commend
both the independent pharmacies and the
community pharmacies for stepping up and
coming forward
and as i said we're working with them to
operationalize them and you'll see that
uh coming through in the nhs plan
a number of people will have been
concerned to hear that the chief medical
officer
suggesting yesterday that you know
christmas time
this year there could still be some
restrictions in place face masks
social distancing what is your view on
all of that
what is the likelihood uh that we will
still have some restrictions i mean the
vaccine
we know is not the uh not the be all and
end all
it is not the only response we all still
have to play our part won't we
of course and and my focus is very much
on vaccine deployment
it is the largest vaccination program in
the history of this country
i think once we begin to make a
difference to those
most vulnerable people so categories one
to four by mid
february we go then all through the the
rest of the categories down to category
nine um but do you still see
restrictions being in place
at christmas uh of the potential for
restrictions being in place at christmas
as
chris whittie said yesterday well i
think as chris whittie has also said is
is
this will be a a political decision and
when we get to that point of inflection
between where community transmission
is really impacted by the vaccination
program
and of course by uh continuing
to ramp up the testing uh infrastructure
in the united kingdom
then the the decision for
government for us is to say well you
know when is it
right to begin to lift some of the
non-pharmaceutical interventions
that we're having to make like the
current uh lockdown that we are
in uh that will be there will come a
moment when we see
where we can basically uh manage this
virus
uh and be able to bring it back under
control
and that is a a decision for the
government
nadeem sahabi good to see you this
morning a busy man indeed thanks for
joining us
thank you